that's the last thing I want that's
probably the biggest regret of my life
in a certain way it couldn't have been
other with my father but I really
regretted that lack there and I've
always felt that lack there's like you
know when my kids I always say I want to
be like a backstop in Little League so
if like I'm like you go out in the world
when you turn around I'm gonna be here
but you go out there and you know
whenever I turned around when I was
young I just felt somebody poaching me
or trying to stab me in the back not
there to sort of go yeah you know what I
mean and it's fine it's just the way
life was and it was fun and it helped me
in many ways to be you know resilient
whatever I didn't even really notice it
until years later when I've begun you
know enough therapy but